[Música]
durante todo junio se celebró el mes del
orgullo de la comunidad lgtb
28 de junio se conmemora el día
internacional ya que en ese en esa
jornada se produjeron los disturbios de
stonewall en la ciudad de nueva york en
eeuu la idea de esta conmemoración es la
autoafirmación y la visibilidad de las
personas que pertenecen a esta comunidad
o movimiento de la gvt y más además de
concientizar sobre la lucha que continúa
por la igualdad y la dignidad de las
personas que pertenecen a esta comunidad
para ello entonces quiero saludar a
nuestro primer invitado del día ls pedro
paradiso el presidente de la fundación
de igualdad y miembro en la red por la
igualdad en américa latina y el caribe
pedro gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24
le pregunto pero por el balance este mes
es del orgullo que acabó en el pasado
mes de junio que apenas despedimos ayer
bueno en principio ha sido muy
importante porque luego de la de las
consecuencias no de las terribles
consecuencias que mostraron la
desigualdad y
la brecha en lo que significa el
ejercicio de los derechos humanos a
nivel mundial y a nivel regional con la
pandemia del cob y el ha sido muy
importante para muchos de los países de
nuestra querida región de américa latina
y el caribe porque hemos podido salir a
la calle a visibilizar a celebrar a
resistir y también a luchar por los
derechos que todavía faltan entonces
para nosotros esto ha sido muy
importante
porque más allá de las dificultades más
allá de las diferentes realidades que
vivimos en nuestra américa latina y el
caribe que es tan diversa el es cierto
que es un día para nosotros en todo el
mundo donde podemos no solamente
visibilizar nuestras orientaciones
sexuales nuestras identidades
nuestro movimiento en nuestra comunidad
sino también podemos reclamar a los
estados y visibilizar sobre todo las
situaciones de vulneraciones de derechos
humanos que viven las personas que
vivimos las personas en todo el mundo en
base a nuestra orientación sexual a
nuestra identidad de género o expresión
entonces creo que ha sido muy importante
el ha sido un mes también bastante
contradictorio porque así como hemos
hemos visto muchos avances también hemos
visto muchos retrocesos claro
enfoquémonos primero pedro en esos
avances la situación realmente de los
avances y los logros que ha logrado la
comunidad lgtb en américa latina y el
caribe
sí yo creo raúl que bueno ha sido muy
importante el contexto en la región
digamos
en toda la región bueno eso estoy
hablando desde un país que quizás es un
país de vanguardia a nivel internacional
con lo que son las leyes no el de la
igualdad como el matrimonio igualitario
la identidad de género el tema del cupo
la iniciación laboral travesti trans la
educación sexual integral el
reconocimiento de las filiaciones de las
familias las restas derechos sexuales y
reproductivos la educación sexual
integral pero esto digamos también ha
tenido un gran reflejo y también un gran
camino histórico del movimiento el eje
tucumana en la región gracias a diversas
organizaciones que luchan y trabajan en
el territorio no ha sido muy importante
para nuestra región por por ejemplo algo
muy fuerte y creo que también es una
bisagra un antes y un después de una
herramienta fundamental para quienes
somos defensores defensoras de derechos
humanos y activistas o militantes el eje
de pq más como la opinión consultiva 24
interamericana de derechos humanos
ha sido un gran avance que permitió no
solamente a costa rica el aprobar la ley
de matrimonio igualitario sino también
que obliga a todos los estados del
continente americano a todos los estados
que han ratificado y firmado la
convención americana a cumplir con esos
mandatos y esa opinión consultiva
histórica también sí muy importante la
relatoría el eje cívico de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
ha hecho un trabajo muy importante en
todos estos años para poder desde los
organismos regionales impulsar la agenda
de derechos y denunciar las violaciones
no la vulneración de derechos que sigue
siendo terrible en toda la región
especialmente por supuesto que hay tanto
traiciones como también también hay el
hay comunidades dentro de nuestra de
nuestros movimientos que son las que más
tienen el impacto de ese fundamentalismo
del odio de la violencia no si pedro le
pregunta ahora que nos falta como región
para alcanzar
a igualdad en los derechos civiles de
todos los que habitamos no sólo en la
región sino también en todo el mundo
y yo creo que nos falta nos falta más
democracia
nos falta yo siempre digo que nosotros
decimos que desde la fundación igualdad
y desde la red por la igualdad en
américa latina y el caribe el que sus
movimientos desde el sur global porque
también eso es importante aclararlo
también lamentablemente durante muchos
años y para que tengas una idea el 95
por ciento de los del financiamiento de
los ingresos de los recursos que existen
en el mundo los maneja el norte global o
se utilizan en el norte global y esto
hace un descalabro muy importante en la
región y sobre todo para avanzar en
nuestra región donde es terrible la
cantidad de impunidad y la falta de
acceso a la justicia y a los derechos
porque nuestro nuestro continente
nuestra región sobre todo de américa
latina y el caribe todavía se sigue
criminalizando
a las personas por su orientación sexual
o su identidad de género sigue habiendo
muchas violencias los crímenes de odio
son moneda corriente
hay un tema muy grave que tiene que ver
con el avance los grupos
fundamentalistas anti derechos que están
muy organizados y que además tienen una
cantidad de recursos que muy muy muy
falta hay una falta de equilibrio en ese
sentido para poder responder los hoteles
de la sociedad civil y por eso es muy
importante y decía que para muchos de
nosotros la democracia no llego para
muchas personas el eje cívico más la
región de américa latina y el caribe la
democracia aún es una promesa es sólo un
deseo porque muchas personas
lesbianas gay bisexuales trans e
intersex en el mundo personas no
binarias personas el
derecho a ser diferente en relación a
las orientaciones sexuales e identidades
de género todavía seguimos teniendo
condenas privativas de la libertad
condenas de muerte en el mundo y sobre
todo estados que no se implican y que no
tienen políticas públicas y
legislaciones que protejan
estoy hablando de lo que es el
matrimonio itario no cosas más básicas
como el derecho a la vida que es esto
que hablábamos recién de la violencia en
los crímenes de odio incluso él también
es un gran problema que tenemos en la
región sobre todo en centroamérica en
los países de centroamérica y el caribe
el ángulo del francófono de
invisibilidad absoluta y la migración
donde por ejemplo hay muchos lugares
donde es muy difícil ser activistas es
muy difícil promover los derechos y las
tienen que escapar sí y sobre todo pero
no hay que olvidar también la violencia
sobre todo que dentro de la comunidad
tlgb tyc más sufren las personas
transexuales pero lamentablemente se me
acaba el tiempo para seguir conversando
sobre este tema que tiene muchísimas
aristas y que pues da mucho para hablar
pero pues esperemos que sea una próxima
oportunidad un abrazo